Автори протекціоністського законопроекту "Купуй українське, плати українцям" запевняють:
він допоможе українським виробникам і поліпшить економічне становище України.
Після затвердження законопроекту у першому читанні
його вщент розкритикували, зокрема в мінекономіки і в ЄС.
Нині в ході визначення переможця державних тендерів ключовим критерієм є ціна:
чим менша - тим більше шансів на перемогу в тендері.
Новий законопроект пропонує додатковий критерій - українське походження товару або послуги.
Цей показник складатиме 20-30 відсотків у загальній оцінці тендерної пропозиції.
Простими словами, перемагатиме не той, хто пропонує товар за найнижчою ціною,
а той, у кого є докази походження сировини чи комплектуючих з України,
наявність сервісних центрів в Україні тощо.
За підрахунками експертів, навіть якщо український виробник
пропонуватиме ціну на 43% вищу від закордонного, він все одно переможе.
У цьому, на думку експертів, головний ризик законопроекту:
держава значно переплачуватиме за товари і послуги, які могла б отримати дешевше.
А значить - переплачуватимуть і прості споживачі.
До того ж, відсутність здорової конкуренції погано вплине на якість української продукції.
Критикують і те, що українським виробникам довести свою "вітчизняність" теж буде непросто.
За оцінками мінекономіки, на це знадобиться щонайменше понад двадцять довідок.
Враховуючи, що щодня проводяться до п'яти тисяч тендерів з тисячами учасників,
перевірка такої купи довідок може зайняти багато часу
і вимагатиме ще більшої кількості чиновників.
Ба більше, забюрократизована процедура доведення походження
може призвести до нових корупційних схем, коли замовники товарів і послуг
будуть відсіювати "чужих" і обирати "своїх".
Крім того, ухвалення протекціоністського закону
суперечетиме низці міжнародних угод, підписаних Україною.
Зокрема угоді про асоціацію і зону вільної торгівлі з ЄС.
Держави, які відчують на собі дію закону,
можуть запровадити дзеркальні торговельні обмеження для українських виробників,
що, відповідно, завдасть їм шкоди.
Закон "Купуй українське" - популістський
і може нашкодити як українським виробникам, так і споживачам.
Він призведе до погіршення якості українських товарів і до їх подорожчання.
Через закон прозорість публічних закупівельзменшиться,
а от корупційні ризики для учасників навпакизростуть.